I don't know about you I've always loved
those reality shows where an expert
steps in and helps a family figure out
how to make tasty practical meals in
their own kitchen those are the best
shows I'm not reading that on a cart I
really believe that
well anyway our show is a completely new
take on that genre here's a peek at a
show we call kitchen crashers do your
mealtimes feel like I can't deal time
shaking things up in the kitchen can be
a snap
I'm Kelly mandrews and this is kitchen
crashers this is Erica and Adam Sussman
they both have busy lives but when it
comes to feeding their family of four
mealtimes are a real scavenger hunt
sometimes I feel like our kitchen is
full of half-finished recipes and
sometimes I feel like trust in our
nation's essential institutions is
eroding faster than we can repair it put
the pedal to the metal and crash their
kitchen
[Applause]
okay I see some eggs and some ham that's
perfect for itself Esther Quezada
prasada
[Music]
on kitchen crashers
you
you